book TV every weekend on c-span - next
on book TV Amy reading presents a
history of economic cons in the United
States and specifically recounts the
confidence game that left Texas rancher
J Frank Norfleet penniless in 1919 it's
about 45 minutes hello thank you so much
for coming so first let's talk about the
big con before I dive into reading from
the book because you need to know a
little bit about what happened to the
main character J Frank Norfleet before
we get to the section that I'm going to
read so it's December 1919 J Frank
Norfleet is a Texan Rancher he's 54
years old in the prime of his life he
has made a bunch of money for himself he
is fairly prosperous and he has made
that money by hewing to his principles
which are include doing business with a
handshake with other honest upright
people you can see what this is going he
comes to Dallas for a land deal from the
Texas Panhandle where he's from and very
quickly he is ensnared by a team of
swindlers five men and they're headed by
their ringleader joseph fury and they've
they've done their research on him they
understand that who Norfleet is and
exactly how to take him and over a
series of almost two weeks they very
gradually and snare him in what we now
know as the big con a particular
structure of swindling that is a little
bit too long to describe here but if
you've seen the sting then you know what
I'm talking about it's a it's an entire
play with sets and actors and costumes
and extras and it basically boiled down
to Joseph's fury convincing Norfleet
that he was placing money on a stock
exchange using insider tips so he
couldn't possibly go wrong
and it was worth his while to put quite
a bit of his own money
behind this absolutely sure thing and
the stock market was in fact rigged it
was just rigged completely against him
and the whole thing was a set so this
all happens in the first chapter of my
book and that chapter ends with him
realizing he has been taken for
everything he's worth plus a bunch more
the swindlers actually play the con on
him twice because he was so invested in
the story they were telling him that he
went home and got more money and played
the con again after he had been swindled
and so he was fifty four four no I'm
sorry forty five thousand dollars poorer
at the end of these two weeks and he was
absolutely stone broke so that the end
of the con the last act in the play
calls for the mark to go home
silent and never say what has happened
to him both because his reputation could
not survive such a mortification but
also because the mark thinks that he has
been participating in something shady or
underhanded in that if he tries to
prosecute his swindlers he himself will
be open to prosecution so in this way
the swindlers buy the mark silence but
Jay frank Norfleet was no ordinary mark
and he made the extraordinary decision
to put his entire life on hold
turn his ranch over to his wife and
spend the next what turned out to be
four years tracking down the five men
that swindled him and he had no
credentials to do this no qualification
whatsoever he was not in any way a
detective he knew nothing about where to
find these guys but he was so outraged
and his principles had been so violated
that it made sense for him to do that so
I'm gonna read from the fourth chapter
which is kind of where his unique part
of the story picks up where the part
where he deviates from the con man's
script and he decides to make this
decision and what happens really begins
so chapter four humbug when North Lee
asked himself where in the whole blessed
country to begin looking for five men
skilled in the arts of subterfuge the
image of a little red notebook floated
up before his mind's eye
he hadn't consciously noted it before
but now that he thought about it he
remembered it as Fury's address book he
turned it around in his head put it back
down on the imagined hotel bed where he
first saw it and then on impulse picked
it back up and opened it the mental
trick worked inside he saw a long list
of names written in different hands and
one in particular stuck out to him a mr.
SN Kathy from Corpus Christi
Norfleet knew Kathy well had hired one
of his relatives on the Spade Ranch 30
years earlier and though the name hadn't
stirred anything in him when he first
encountered it he suddenly realized its
potential significance Kathy was now a
landowner like himself and his name was
Shirley in the little red book because
he was on Furies sucker list a flood had
recently devastated Corpus Christi and
North Lee could easily imagine fury
persuading Kathy to liquidate has
already sodden real estate in pursuit of
more durable coinage North Lee's first
trip was to Corpus Christi to see if his
old friend had encountered the gang of
five but he was told that Kathy was away
in California on a prospecting trip it
was Eliza his wife who gave him his next
lead as they sat together one day
talking over the case well Norfleet
cleaned his rifle she mused that when
Spencer one of the five swindlers has
visited their ranch to survey it for the
as we now know mythical green
immigration land company he had spoken
learnedly and amusingly of his travels
all around the country everywhere except
the state of California all mention of
which was conspicuously absent in
Spencer's conversation could it be she
wondered because that is where the gang
hides out you've hit it you've hit it
that's it that's the very reason they
never yipped a word about the Golden
State Norfleet shouted leaping up from
his chair and here I should say that any
dialog in this book is not invented this
is all quoted from something that
Norfleet has written so these are his
authentic words this is what he said his
mind instantly made all of the
connections it all comes to me now see
they made a getaway from here the minute
they got my money he conjectured sure as
shooting they gathered up
via Corpus Christi and the whole outfit
hit it straight for Sonny cow the story
felt so right to him that he wasted no
time
Eliza helped him pack and within two
hours he was on his way to California
this very thinnest of leads shot him all
the way across the plains and deserts to
San Bernardino why San Bernardino well
simply because he had to get off the
train somewhere and he decided to work
the state from the bottom up Norfleet
later offered no other explanation for
charging forth as if this one sufficed
it was dusk when he arrived and the
decorations strung around the town
reminded him that it was Christmas Eve
the holiday had utterly fled his mind
when he'd had his revelation as he
walked around the neighborhood's
imagining the families inside and
wondering what his own family was doing
back at the ranch he experienced the
first and really the only moment of
doubt in his quest he longed to get
right back on the train and return home
before he exposed himself as a fool but
as he walked the sights before his eyes
began to meld with the thoughts
constantly looping through his mind he
caught himself imagining Fury and
Spencer squeezing down chimneys scooping
up the presents and fleeing the way they
had come Norfleet laughed to discover
that he had become inescapably obsessed
then turned in for the night so on
Christmas morning lonely and sheepish
but still resolute Norfleet went to the
sheriff's office and met Walter Shay
Norfleet spilled his entire story to
Sheriff Shaye sparing none of the
details of his own gullibility and
describing his enemies as precisely as
he knew how Shay let him get all the way
to the end of his speech before replying
the Sheriff's Office doesn't make a
general practice of giving every
stranger in town a Christmas present but
I may have one for you it took a moment
for the words to register with Norfleet
the sheriff beckoned him over to the
cells and pointed there in adjoining
cages sat Ward and Gerber the fraudulent
secretaries of the Dallas and Fort Worth
Stock Exchange's Norfleet stomach turned
his entire body broke out in a sweat and
he felt a tingle run up and down his
spine and yet despite his revulsion his
first absurd impulse was to wish his
enemies
a Merry Christmas after all for most of
the time that he'd known warden Gerber
they'd been his esteemed colleagues
crisp well-dressed executives who had
treated him with deference and respect
he marveled at how utterly their effects
had changed and how little they
resembled their former selves Ward
turned to him sullenly and sneered like
a common thief saya found us digi a
damned old fox gerbera the one Norfleet
had picked as the killer in the gang was
Craven normally for God's sake don't
identify as he shouted have mercy on us
have pity on us for God's sake don't
don't identify us keeping his face
impassive Norfleet turned and followed
sheriff Shay back to his office without
a word as soon as they were out of
earshot
Norfleet grilled the sheriff for the
details of their arrest Shay told him an
extraordinary an astonishing a nearly
unbelievable story a Texan by the name
of Kathy did Norfleet know him was in
San Bernardino for business and had
fallen in with a group of phony
stockbrokers he was just about to close
a deal with them when he read in the
newspaper of Norfleet swindle kathy knew
at once that he was in the hands of the
same men - Reno Hamlin as the mule buyer
and he dashed from the hotel room he was
sharing with the swindlers and accosted
the first police officer he saw on the
street alas Fury's crew spotted him
talking to the officer and fled the
hotel
Furion Spencer disappeared via the fire
escape but sheriff Shay managed to
intercept award and Gerber a few minutes
later at the train station he took the
chance of detaining them long enough to
wire sheriff sterling Clark in Fort
Worth and he received an instant reply
to hold them under the warrant that
Norfleet had filed after his swindling
in Ward suitcase they found precisely
the same credentials and documents used
on Norfleet only fury now going by the
name of Peck had bothered to change his
alias the rapid capture of two of his
men did not dampen nor fleet's fervor
for the other three
while the Fort Worth authorities readied
the paperwork to extradite warden Gerber
to Texas Norfleet continued scouring
Southern California for leads on fury
Spencer and Hamlin he searched the
telephone and telegraph records at all
the San Bernardino hotels but found no
trace of mr.
Pech he visited police stations in the
surrounding cities and towns and in Los
Angeles he had a minor score while
looking through the rogues galleries of
photographs he identified a picture of
fury and learned his real name for the
first time and while he was in the big
city he thought he'd try his hand at a
little disguise he left his suitcase at
the sheriff's office and sought out a
suitably adventurous beautician to
wrestle with his mustache a few hours
later a clean-shaven businessman wearing
a neat gray suit walked into the
sheriff's office and asked for his
suitcase say how do you get that way
these things belong to a West Texas cow
man what you're trying to pull off
Norfleet beamed and happiness northeast
escapades in California were soon
brought to a close by a summon from the
Fort Worth district attorney to appear
at a grand jury hearing for Ward and
Gerber's requisition while the two men
fumed in their California jail cells
north Lee caught the next train east to
Texas he sat in the Pullman and thought
about his case his mind restlessly
circulating the same meager facts and
then an elderly man sitting across from
him folded up his newspaper leaned over
and introduced himself as perry Garst
I have just been reading about the
capture of these fellows warden Gerber
it looks like they're in for it now
doesn't it in high spirits nor flea
cried that they would be if he had
anything to do with it and out came the
entire story Garst was riveted by the
time Norfleet finished his tale Garst
had decided to stop at Fort Worth with
him to see how the trial turned out and
in the meantime he leaned in the corner
of the car for a short nap as Norfleet
watched the older man's head tip back
into the seat and the light from the
window play on his features his mind
suddenly froze he knew that face he was
sure he had never met mr. Garza before
but the characteristics of his face were
undeniably familiar and then he had it
perry Garst was exactly what ej ward
would look like in 30 years his newest
friend was he was instantly confident
the father of one of his mortal enemies
sent to tail him and reel out
information from him nor flee cursed his
own egotism of the ignorant for never
even considering that the swindlers just
might be as devious and obscene
as he Garst woke reached for his
suitcase and drew out an elaborate
luncheon of many tempting morsels he
offered them in turn to Norfleet but as
if compensating for his previous
susceptibility Norfleet turned down
everything the sandwiches with their
curly lettuce the stuffed olives the
cream-filled cakes the fruits his
paranoia was strengthened when garthe
refused to eat his own food claiming an
upset stomach and choosing for himself
only two hard-boiled eggs it would be
difficult Norfleet thought savagely to
poison two unbroken shells and this
small act told him all he needed to know
about mr. Perry gharst he resolved to
double his caution and then in
practically the very next instant
Norfleet broke his own resolution his
natural guru leti simply could not be
held back and he soon found himself in
delightful conversation with a woman
from Georgia when he learned that she
had been a detective prior to her
marriage he unstintingly granted her his
confidence telling her his tale of woe
and giving her precise descriptions of
the three men still at large she
promised to keep an eye out for them as
she continued across the country and to
wire him with any leads
Norfleet stepped off the train at Fort
Worth well satisfied with the progress
he'd made cars stuffed off the train
with him but was prohibited from
following Norfleet into the grand jury
hearing north Lee testified against
warden Gerber and as he left the
courthouse Garst seized his arm and
asked feverishly what did they do what
did they do did they build those men
North Lee affected nonchalance he had
done his part he said and the rest was
up to the jury he began to walk away
garcy ice grabbed at him again saying
that the hotels were booked up for a
convention so would Norfleet like to
join him at the roommate secured at a
nearby boardinghouse once again Norfleet
declined then eventually Garst gave up
and took his leave
Norfleet shed his indifference swiveled
around and did his best imitation of a
private eye
trailing gharst into a poor district and
up to the door of a disheveled house
when Garst was safely inside Norfleet
dashed back to the courthouse he
buttonholed Frank Evans a newspaper
reporter and cajoled him into returning
to the boardinghouse hoping to come
Garth's with the knowledge of his true
identity and published it as a scoop on
the next day's front page on the way
back to the boarding house however
Norfleet got lost and by the time they
found at gharst was gone and all traces
of his stay had been erased
Norfleet took that as the strongest
possible evidence that his supposition
of guard's relationship to ward was
correct
Norfolk's testimony that afternoon
secured Ward and Gerber's extradition
from San Bernardino to Fort Worth
sheriff sterling Clark personally
escorted his charges back to Texas by
train and they spent the rest of the
winter in the Tarrant County Jail while
warden Gerber made themselves home there
Norfleet had another conversation that
deflated his swelling sense of triumph
just a little bit he was at the jail
when the pair of swindlers was visited
by GC Cornwall a u.s. Secret Service
agent who helped identify them as
accomplices in the swindling of a
Washington DC man a furniture dealer
named Peter nee Cornwall toad Norfleet
that Ward and Gerber were part of the
infamous fury gang that used to operate
out of New York the photos of all the
leaders are right here in this town
Cornwall informed him I sent them to the
city detective a long time ago and asked
him to be on the watch for them and to
notify me if they appeared North Lee was
not flat by this news how much easier
would his search have been had he
possessed photographs to show to
sheriff's hotel managers and retired
lady detectives you stay here and I'll
go hunt them up and bring you enough
pictures of that gang to make a big
family album Cornwall offered but when
he returned from the sheriff's office he
shook his head in frustration and told
Norfleet that the office was claiming
never to have received the photographs
Norfleet got his first inkling of the
swindling and sleight of hand performed
on the other side of the sheriff's
counter the photographs may have been a
false lead but they gave Norfleet
something invaluable renewed conviction
that only he was responsible for
bringing about justice his
disappointment was soon offset by a
miraculous lead the two swindlers he'd
landed in jail would give him no
information on the other three so he
found himself once again with a wide
open country to scour and then he
received a
her forwarded to him at his hotel in
Fort Worth from the retired lady deck a
man had boarded her train in Houston who
matched nor fleets description of fury
down to the smallest pour the woman
moved close to him and eavesdropped on
his conversation with a colleague he
started by telling the man that business
in Dallas and Fort Worth was as easy as
running a picture show clearly that
could mean only one thing
she leaned in closer he said he was on
his way to Miami to play the game and
then came the kicker as he remarked in a
casual aside and I think I'll stop off a
few days in Jacksonville so many of the
boys are down there and I like to keep
up with the gang and find out who the
new suckers are indubitably
it was fury the wide open country had
telescope down to a single city fury was
squarely in Norfleet sights and just as
soon as he had acquired a small arsenal
of guns a suitcase full of disguises
deputy sheriff's credentials and arrest
warrants for his remaining quarries the
cowpuncher hopped on the next eastbound
train let's take stock first Norfleet
jabbed his finger at random on a map of
California and just happened to find two
of his swindlers they just happened to
have swept a fellow Texan and longtime
friend into the con a man who just
happened to a friend read North Lee its
newspaper account in time to get wise
and kick before he was cleaned out then
North Lee just happened to recognize a
stranger on a train as the father of one
of his swindlers in time to avoid
further endangering himself finally
Norfleet described the ringleader to
another stranger on a train and she just
happened to recognize that man halfway
across the country and obtained
precisely the information that Norfleet
needed to track him down all this in
just twenty pages of his autobiography
either the world with several orders of
magnitude smaller in the 1920s or
something other than strict
verisimilitude guides north leads
account of these events the first
question his story raises is could he be
conning us his autobiography piles on
the improbabilities without everyone's
acknowledging that they are in
probabilities he plays it so straight
that it comes to seem like winking
for instance the lady detective whom he
meets on on the train on his way to ward
and Grover's hearing is named mrs. ward
as far as I know he says neutrally this
mrs. ward was in no way related to
either EJ ward or his probable kin parry
gharst it was merely a coincidence
later in hot pursuit of Joseph's theory
he approaches the police officer on a
street corner in st. Augustine Florida
who turns out to be named Ward Norfleet
merely rights would I never get rid of
the ward family on the one hand perhaps
Norfleet should be commended for
sticking to the truth of his narrative
even when he risks our incredulity with
particulars that no novelist could get
away with on the other hand perhaps
these inscrutable details and asides
should signal something to his readers
the narrative sounds quite different
from noir fleets early life history
instead of self-righteousness and moral
rectitude Norfleet projects a hokey
humor and an extreme tolerance for moral
ambiguity when he finds himself almost
broke in southern california he takes a
jaunt down to the race tracks at Tijuana
he finds a Texas horse on the program
and bets his last 90 dollars it would be
a poor Texas horse who couldn't win a
little money for a Texas cow man I
thought according to the autobiography
my little baby Juan and paid out at six
to one this from the same man who banned
gambling from his ranch and preached to
young men on living up to their mother's
expectations
Norfleet justifies his vigilante quest
as an attempt to restore his cowboy
values that had been so soo merrily
violated by the urban tricksters but
when he leaves his ranch and embarks on
that quest his values begin to drift
away from their origins and he starts to
resemble his enemies more than he
realizes
take a man with a propensity for
spinning yarns by the campfire and then
immersive and the deceptive arts of the
swindler suddenly he almost seems to be
impersonating himself and daring us to
believe him but this prompts a second
and far more beguiling question if he is
yes do we mind arguably the most
defining and perplexing characteristic
of an American sense of fun is a
perennial willingness to make oneself
into the mark of a show man an artist or
a director you might also say a writer
audiences and spectators have relished
the very particular pleasure of
accepting an invitation into a story
they know might be false only to be
immersed in it completely and then duped
at the end by what they thought was true
it is a sensation that is composed of
equal parts admiration for the
cleverness of the ploy and gratification
at a neat resolution and it has a long
pedigree in American culture now the
rest of the chapter goes on to detail
that pedigree in American culture and
the rest of the book goes on to tell
about Norfleet story and how actually it
really is true but I wanted to give you
a flavor of why it's kind of interesting
to poke at his own story a little bit
and I wanted to end with a paragraph
from the very end of the book so you can
see where that poking brings us in the
end to this idea of a sort of American
sense of fun nor Fleitz life is the
story of triumphing over his
susceptibility by embracing it perhaps
one of the reasons why he captivated so
many listeners and readers with his tale
is that he gave expression to an aspect
of his identity that few would otherwise
be able to admit they shared
Norfleet never possessed that hard
carapace of skepticism that the experts
of his day tried to instill in the
American populace instead he let out his
inner mark that fragile bubble of hope
and optimism it's what led him into
Fury's trap but it's also what led him
to believe he had a chance at succeeding
on his quixotic quest two stories that
would never have happened without a
large measure of gullibility
certainly this credulity is as essential
to American mythology as the self-made
man but north leads adventurers go
further to suggest that the mark inside
is the first requirement for narrative
itself what he did is cultivate this
characteristic until it became knowing
self-aware perennial II game for a kind
of wide awake deception
Norfleet came to represent the
personality type that best fits american
modernity the sophisticated sucker i
would love to hear questions stories of
your own conning any kind of discussion
we can have and when you discover the
subject it instantly strike you as
something that was kind of endemic in
the american psychology or was that
something that kind of came to you as
you were studying I first discovered nor
flee when I was researching my
dissertation which is much more boring
and but I was writing a chapter on
autobiographies by con artists which are
very interesting and there weren't any
before the beginning of the 20th century
and then there were a whole bunch and
these memoirs were fascinating to me
because how do you convince your readers
that you're telling the truth in a
memoir when your profession is that of a
liar so there's all kinds of rhetorical
strategies that they engage in on the
page and that struck me as very American
and not particular just to the genre of
memoir but and but then also there was
clearly a fascination with their stories
in this time and it's exactly the time
that the big con came about so as I was
researching these stories I really
wanted to read a book that would kind of
tell me the history of con games and
what was popular win what was in fashion
what matched up with the economic
opportunities at the time right because
all of these cons are parasitic on
mainstream real life legitimate
investment potential right and there was
no such book so there was this hole in
my mind that needed to be filled and
then the other thing that happened was I
discovered Norfleet and I thought that
his book was similar
to the memoirs that I was researching
that it was it wasn't true none of those
conman memoirs are true and I thought
well his is obviously not true because
that's way too good to be true it's this
amazing adventure story and so it's
obviously a false memoir of someone
lying about being in the deceptive arts
and that seemed really interesting and
useful to me I can I can do a lot with
this but then I found out it was true
and then that seemed like a good place
to start
to write the book that tried to period
i's con games and talk about the ways
that they have been pretty crucial to
the economic development in our country
so it's a good story but it's also a
kind of story from the underground and
so a way to get at an underground
history as well
I know people in this room have been
conned statistically it's likely so if
you'd like to tell the story
you would see in today's society that
kind of mirror well we all know now
about Ponzi schemes thanks to Bernie
Madoff and so that's an instance of a
very old con that's from the beginning
of the 20th century but it's continued
and nearly unchanged form to the present
day and in fact even in just the past
two years which is well after Madoff
made headlines he was first exposed in
2008 but even in just the past two years
the SEC has continued to prosecute over
200 Ponzi schemes which I find really
incredible and it gives the lie to the
idea that once you know how a con has
worked you aren't susceptible to it
anymore you actually can't necessarily
be inoculated against it and so some
cons don't die out and are not
particular to a particular moment in
history and so Ponzi is the best
instance of that and actually a few
weeks ago there was an article about an
Amish man who ran a Ponzi scheme so yeah
it's true and his he didn't intend to
defraud investors but he did so that's
one answer to your question that another
answer would be well of course there are
plenty of cons that are particular to
our time and they all happen on the
Internet
so the most famous one that we all know
about because we've all gotten the
emails is the Nigerian 401 9 schemes and
they're not all from Nigeria but that's
the that's the name of the con if you go
to the SEC website that's what they're
gonna warn you against and that's the
one where there's some deposed Nigerian
prince or you know some high up
executive they actually a lot of them
come out of the Middle East now as well
and they've got some sort of treasure
that's locked up in some bureaucratic
way but you can help them unlock that
treasure in some complicated way that
will generally involve them traveling to
lots of foreign countries but if you
invest in that cause you'll get a share
of that treasure and it's hard to
believe how it works but it's it has a
similar structure to the big con in that
no one can ever
be swindled by something that's to
obviously not true or implausible that's
to obviously magical money to obviously
something for nothing
but lots of people can be swindled by
this idea that if you spend a little bit
of money oftentimes in friendship or
altruism which is what the Nigerian 4:09
scheme plays on spend a little bit of
money then you'll get a lot back and
it's a you know a sort of easy entry
that plays on greed but also and a lot
of times plays on other things like like
friendship or so I think we all have
those emails and our spam filters right
now they just get through they must work
or they wouldn't keep sending them when
I was reading it I thought the story was
very familiar but I couldn't think of
another example what was someone who was
kind and then
to take revenge are there other stories
that you found in your research yeah
it's a truism in these conman
autobiographies that I've read and you
know anytime a a swindler is bragging
about his exploits he'll say that the
sucker never squeals because the con is
so deviously structured that the mark is
ashamed or fearful of being prosecuted
right so but as I research Norfleet
story I found lots of instances of
suckers squealing they squeal all the
time they go to the you know nearest
district attorney or police station and
will tell their story what happens is
that the story just ends right there
because those people are all bought off
and they're never gonna go after the
swindlers but there are a few instances
of swindlers that are sorry of Marx who
did what Norfleet did who then just took
it into their own hands to go after
these guys I mean it's kind of
incredible to think of you actually just
going off on this madcap quest it's just
so impossible that you could be
successful at that so why would you even
try but I did find a few other I mean
they're not they're not famous people
but there are newspaper accounts and
then I shared the manuscript with a
group of graduate students at Cornell
and one woman's grandfather had had
pulled in Norfleet and he had actually
he was from Canada he had been swindled
in Florida which is where everyone
swindled in the wintertime the swindlers
go down there and he had been down there
for some Sun he had lost all his savings
he had gone home and then he went back
to Florida and he got his conmen and
when he died many years later that's
what they talked about as at his funeral
because that was you know the
extraordinary story of his life and so
it's not a common story but it's not as
uncommon as maybe the conman would have
you believe
hmm was there anything you left out of
your story that you know at some point
you have to say okay this is the story
and I can't include every single thing
that I want
oh yes you mean specifically about
Norfleet or just in general yeah well I
mean there's a lot that I did right that
got cut because I got very interested in
the story in North Lee's own personal
history so I went deep into Texas
Panhandle history I just found that very
interesting then later the second half
of the book Norfleet goes to Denver and
Denver is this completely fixed up town
where the swindlers basically control
everything and there are there are many
overlapping teams of swindlers swindling
Marx all at the same time it's
incredible and I went deep into that
history as well because how did that how
did that town of anywhere become this
this absolutely safe place for swindling
and there's a you know a very specific
answer that has to do with Denver
history but that had to be shortened but
in terms of North Waites own story
absolutely his autobiography is packed
with various storylines and and I just
had to pare that down because my book
would be as long as his book plus three
more at least so he he got you know he I
don't think I'm spoiling anything by
saying he does eventually get his
swindlers but there are many different
twists and turns along the way and he
narrates every single one of them he
didn't have an editor so I had to be the
editor and telling a story but there are
also parts of the story he didn't know
at least when he wrote the
autobiographies so when he goes after
Joe Fury the ringleader he finally gets
him but then the story of what happens
after fury goes to jail is just
fantastic and that's not in northland
autobiography so I did get to add some
things in let's just say that fury he
doesn't want to be locked up in fear he
doesn't want to be locked up like he'll
he was clever enough to figure out at
least a partial solution so I added
things in and then I edited out one
instance of North Lee's autobiography
there's this woman named mrs. street and
she's this small sort of trim neat
little woman and
she turns up everywhere he goes and she
turns out to be incredibly deadly and
devious and she is not what she seems
but nothing ever happens with that so I
took her out cuz I couldn't really
figure out a way but but if you like
this story you can Norfleet
autobiography is there to read and it's
a I mean it's a page-turner it's um very
hokey and it's the dialogue because he
loved that maybe he really spoke that
way but but the stories are they're
great they're long-winded Google
morpholino the stuff magically pops up
well a lot pops up when you google noir
flow yeah I mean so so how do I mean
that's a perfect question how do you
research this story I mean on the one
hand you it you have to research it
because his autobiography is so
implausible so you have to fact-check it
or you know sort of do due diligence but
he was just this ordinary guy I mean he
was as uneducated you know not
well-known person and so but he very
quickly enters the public record and
it's mainly newspapers and they did his
story was incredibly interesting to
people in the time so newspapers not
just in Texas but all across the country
very quickly began following his
exploits and he became known for what he
was doing and you know his name became a
shorthand for going after people that
have criminals not even just necessarily
common but you know going after a
criminal
and so then so but you know newspapers
will you know he can he can game the
newspapers themselves if he wants to I
mean he's not he's not actually conning
anyone but he is exaggerating his story
a little bit so how do you penetrate
that level of falsehood so then there
are court documents that detail what
happened to each of the men that he
caught and there's court transcripts
interestingly the main court case that I
would have liked to have used when he
does make it to Denver and he tries to
bring down the den
her Khan gang I mean this is a whole
nother story that I didn't get into and
what I read tonight but it's you know
that's this thirty-plus no no much more
than that team of swindlers that I've
got this stranglehold in the city of
Denver and of course he's going to be
the one to bring them all to justice and
and there was a trial and it was
extensive and it's completely missing
from the Denver courthouse records and
if you go to the microfilm the court you
know just numerically the court case
right before it and right after it are
there and somebody just photographed in
the microfilm and note saying these
records are missing and so there's a
story there that I don't know and you
have to wonder who would have been hurt
by that being public and then you know
lots of local sources iight ride as hard
as I could to track down descendents of
the people in the book not because they
would you know remember anything but
because they would have letters and
scrapbooks and I did find some of that
and unpublished autobiography by someone
a Texas district attorney who
accompanied Norfleet on a lot of his
escapades and he did say in his
autobiography well you know Norfleet
exaggerated a little bit but you know he
mostly verified the actual events so in
the end what's amazing about Northwoods
story is how much we can verify how much
didn't just disappear into this you know
sort of ordinary life but how much made
it into the public record and how much
he was telling the truth but slanting it
so that he was pretty much always be
here either with north lead or with
others did you come across we the the
iconic dedicated smart tough lawman kind
of thing is is so replete in our
literature but seemingly I
unless though in reality and did you
occasionally come across those those
people or even ever so you mean like a
sheriff or a police officer or yeah
there were a few the sheriff Shay that I
mentioned in the excerpt that I read
tonight was one of the honest ones and
there was um there were a few that
helped North Lee out along the way but
but by and large I mean there were there
was so much corruption and I tell some
of those stories in here I mean he
encountered so many people who were
bought off or you know all these double
dealings and that became his sort of
sideline to was to expose that and bring
that to light and so he had this sort of
you know little hobby
along the way of his main quest which
was to bring down the crooked police
officers so he was the lawman the mythic
figure that you're describing he was
very much styling himself after a kind
of dime novel American mythic hero right
he's part cowboy part detective you know
it was sort of a noir sense who is
familiar with the underworld but not
tainted by it he's you know some of the
other what are some other genres so I
think he was taking that on and that
might have been why other people were so
interested in his story is that well
here it is for real here is someone
who's isn't managed to be ensnared in
the corruption that everyone can see
around them but yes there were some
honest police officers but none of them
took on the quest like Norfleet did so
none of them would have been able to
really break apart the structures that
were so deeply embedded in these fixed
up towns it took someone completely
outside of all of those and completely
oblivious to you know the norms to kind
of come in and blow it all apart and
bring publicity to it and that kind of
thing
did nor plates film survived when he
made yeah so he made he started to make
a silent film starring himself produced
by himself financed largely by himself
and right before the Great Depression
and so it never was finished and all we
know is that one of the actresses sued
him for something which is curious
because there are actually any women
roughly its story so I don't know what
role she might have taken in this and no
the film does not survive there are a
few stills and that's it I mean I've
looked but I don't know what happened to
it which is such a shame the stills are
amazing there's there are a few in the
book
I mean it's they're so campy but you
know that's the era of silent films back
then but you know he's periodic bushes
with a gun and he's got the eyeliner on
and so it would have been it would have
been good
he saw the filmic potential of his own
story like he saw this this this belongs
on the big screen but alas another
moment of American history in her feet I
mean I just see I see Paul Newman in
that role because he's not so North it
was very short five four which is
interesting to think about him in
relation to the con men are all very
towering and so I think of Paul Newman
he's got the light blue eyes mostly
heavies penetrating blue eyes and then I
think of Paul Newman in the sting so I
don't know I don't know let's play that
game who else was I mean new a play my
because it can't be someone you know
it's not like a Brad Pitt hero that's
not who Norfleet is right it's gotta be
I don't know with James Franco do a good
job
I don't know somebody with a little I
aren't you know that you were doing well
John Stewart Robert damages Jon Stewart
oh I'll tell them that we talked tonight
and you've all agreed yeah it'd be good
there's um you know the the as these
things happen you publish a book and
then people try to sell it in Hollywood
and it competes with all the other books
that people are trying to sell in
Hollywood and the feedback that we've
gotten is that Hollywood wants a really
bloody shootout in the end they went
Norfleet to you know come into some kind
of fight with his con men which he
doesn't that's the whole point of the
book is that he could have his cowboy
sons of justice would have entitled him
to to kill these guys but he made the
choice early on to catch them by guile
so that means he's gonna not have a
bloody shootout so Hollywood doesn't get
the book I am I misunderstood
so no yet yes I think I've seen that a
while ago it was this great show about
new his Connors but one of the things
they they try to they sort of make a
moral distinction between those were
people that really are really greedy for
an unethical and versus just someone
that might get bought into kind of a
swindle have you seen any Connors that
sort of real-life made that kind of
right seeming like con men that aren't
gonna swindle the you know the retiree
on a small pension they're gonna go
after the one who's really greedy
that is another truism that appears
everywhere in every autobiography or
every sociological interview that every
con man ever gave that they only swindle
the people who have it coming and that
their swindles work by greed and only a
greedy person would respond to it and I
don't buy it
I I think they would send all anyone
that they could and because the truth is
they didn't just appeal to greed they
appealed to a lot of really nice
emotions that we should be proud we have
including intelligence and kindness and
so I think that's a very self-justifying
you have to take that with a grain of
salt but they you know
they they consider themselves the
aristocrats of the criminal world
because they don't use violence and
because apparently they're you know
choosy about who they swindle and now
it's true
hello more what's your next book gonna
be about thank you for asking I don't
know yet I'm researching a bunch of
ideas and haven't narrowed them down but
I'm interested in American history and
I'm interested in capitalism that's a
very large category but it would be
something in there not swindling it
would be nice to spend some time with
some good people but we'll see I don't
know thank you rapping thank you very
much for coming I'll be signing books
over there and I would love to talk with
you more individually and what a
pleasure thank you very much this event
was hosted by the Elliot Bay book
company in Seattle for more information
visit Elliot Bay book calm
with the US Senate on break the rest of
this week we're featuring